hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to maple county i saw this
game and i had to play it so i literally
stopped what i was doing which is not
really an excuse because i was cleaning
and i was doing the dishes i stopped
that dropped it immediately and i had to
play this game not an excuse it's a
service to you
you're welcome
attention maple county police department
please take a seat your training video
will begin momentarily
for this interactive training video
please remain seated
pick up the remote on the table in front
of you and give inputs when required
thank you
the remote
what remote this interactive training
video is brought to you by maple
county's police department
in this instructional video you will
learn about the current threats sweeping
our state and how to protect yourself
and citizens from this threat we know
very little about this threat but as we
learn and grow our knowledge this step
will be removed in the following months
the media has not revealed this threat
and everything you see in this training
video is classified
sharing this information with friends or
loved ones is not permitted
[Music]
exercise one assessing the threat do you
count as friends or loved ones on screen
two images will appear on instinct alone
please choose the image that is the most
unsettling you will be scored at the end
of this video okay
i mean
there's something weird about the eyes
here
i feel like this is a trick i feel like
there's some i'm gonna go with it
oh no oh no
oh no i think i gotta go with bugeye
fishman here
i'm uncomfortable how about you oh
that's fine
oh
well you know if i just gotta go on
instinct i would say that that's not too
comfortable there was that the criteria
what makes me um
every time i see my old house i feel
sick to my stomach who's talking right
now
i can't get his eyes out of my head
whose eyes is that a ufo
it's a nufo he was weightless almost
floating
dash from room to room like a puppet on
strings
do i gotta pick this but i think there's
somebody in my kitchen
there
better not be i was doing my dishes i
was supposed to do that
you don't get to do my dishes
congratulations you passed the first
exercise great next we will learn more
and how to identify a threat reports
have identified these characteristics
lack of emotion and uncanny facial
features
body language mirroring and verbal
imitation okay
lack of eye tracking and awkward
movement what happened to your voice
oh
i think somebody's in my bedroom
well
oh really
oh
oh well this is not what i thought was
going to happen
oh i'm playing i'm in i'm living
i think someone's in my bedroom
oh
god i can't see
hello
hi
everything's so
wiggly uh
man i should clean my walls there seems
to be a lot of blood and or jam
unusually long limbs
can you come in my room
i fell down
i need help
i need you to see something
come to my room
mom's dead it is tricking you
or is it the police won't help you
or will they play dead
how
oh i'm playing i'm not going to touch
anything
you're not playing dead well enough
unusually long limbs
[Music]
sheriff's department uh hi so this could
be nothing but there's this really
[ __ ] freaky dude that's been chasing
my house i think
well uh can you describe him to me at
least um
i mean it's like pitch black outside but
um i i think he might be i might judge
or something he's moving like really
weird
well uh
doing anything illegal or i know [ __ ]
you guys [ __ ] nothing happens out
here just [ __ ] send someone jesus
[ __ ] i'm i'm sorry
i'm just freaked out man it's just this
[ __ ] never happened all right what's he
doing right now
[ __ ] um
jesus
right he's just
he just kind of
i mean he definitely knows i'm looking
at him
and he knows i'm calling the cops
hopefully he'll [ __ ] off but i don't
know if something's just
off oh
what's your interest it's uh no
road
yeah just try to hurry but my mom's
passed out in the other room i'm not
trying to like wake her up and freak her
out of the [ __ ] day she had
yep
we'll see you soon
oh dogs why do you have to park now
don't park now my mandela catalog what
the hell is
[Music]
what is mandela catalog
oh
well i don't like that
we are currently receiving countless
reports of an unidentified hostile
organism that will refer to as
alternates
until we have a complete understanding
of the threat it's important to stay
home lock all doors and windows and have
access to a loaded firearm or any ranged
weapon at all times
you will know if an alternate exists
solely based on their physical
characteristics
if you see another person that looks
identical to you run away and hide
if you see a person that has a
biologically impossible characteristic
run away and hide if one manages to
break into your home refrain from any
kind of communication or contact with
the threat these intelligent life forms
utilize elements of psychological
warfare to take advantage of their
victims
while we heavily discourage any form of
contact or communication with an
alternate we make exceptions for
attempts at executing them yourself
[Music]
well good i'm glad that that still
stands
i've never heard of this i've never
heard of this think principle tell an
authority thing okay
who who's an authority figure hinderer
i'm not going to be able to remember
these words
identify
the class type
like math
neutralize the alternate if it is safe
to do so
kill yourself
hmm
well i don't like that principle
i don't think that's a good principle
no your place in rio oh
that's not even less good
more good
know your enemy
type one doppelganger
which one
type three
well this is a piece of uh terrifying
information that i didn't know that i
needed i in fact i don't even think that
i need it
victim one victim two
or are they alternates mark heathcliff
caesar taurus
hey it's caesar i hope it's not too late
no it's fine don't worry what's up are
you right
yeah
it's not me it's my mom
she's not go cold and i have no idea why
i'm on my way to the er but could you do
me a favor
yeah of course what is it
i just need you to come over and turn on
the cameras we have set up
you know the ones that we installed
after we were robbed
oh yeah
would you mind if i asked why
well she screamed really loud right
before i found her on the ground
i i just well do you have your doors and
windows locked like what the broadcast
told us to do
yeah that's the weird part
maybe she saw something i don't i don't
know
all right
i mean it shouldn't be too bad
i'm just gonna switch them on and get
out of there though you know how i feel
about your house
yeah that's fine
one last thing try to get a good view
hey
there's a smiley face okay
all right i gotta go i'm almost at the
hospital thank you
oh okay all right well hope your mom's
okay
this don't look like the hospital
oh
oh i see
i'm so fascinated this took a turn i
didn't expect
and did they say like episode one
doesn't mean there's more of these i
mean i i freaking love this type of
stuff
it's just like
[Music]
it's so
satisfying
to
like immerse yourself in this
nightmare scenario
oh good
i'm not gonna like this am i
what am i looking at
oh it was like a bar it was a bar it was
like a shed out back with the door ah
that's a problem
who are you
get away from me
no
oh
all right
[Music]
it
let me in mark
i have a gift for you
i have a present
i have a surprise
all right well then you don't have to
that's your choice after all it's like a
vampire can't come in without permission
[Music]
oh that's not good
you [ __ ] bastard
oh
for me me specifically what are you
talking about me
what do you mean
i don't like that i i only make good
decisions like doing my dishes when i'm
supposed to
oh hi
hey how are you doing
good to see you could you step back a
bit
if you'd like to make a call please hang
up and try again
if you need help hang up and then dial
your operator
if you'd like to make a call please hang
up and try again
if you need help hang up
hmm
i see
viewing the following footage is illegal
and punishable by law if you've not been
previously cleared with your assistant
uh if you have access to this recording
and you're not part of local authority
please stop the video and discard the
taping well i guess i probably has
permission
oh
it's the thing
while at the station a situation may
occur where the local 911 dispatchers
run out of operators to handle calls so
they are given to us instead
there are three and only three scenarios
that you will handle with a caller
when a caller needs a police send
available personnel to the address
when the caller has a fire-related
emergency contact our neighboring fire
department with the address and a brief
description of the event
when the caller has a medical emergency
immediately contact the mandela
community hospital
i feel trained i feel very
here at the trained county police
department we thank you for viewing this
instructions
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
uh-huh
is this because they might be an
alternate
ah
oh
oops
nothing is worth the risk nothing is
worth the risk nothing is worth the risk
toddler stresses
oh record your child's responses to the
fall will be oh good
i'm basically a toddler so
[Music]
low low stress no stress
peace calmness
ah
i recorded it you're watching it
slightly stressed
slightly slightly more stressed
[Music]
tom
daddy didn't talk me
there's a man in the closet
interesting
well this is a fascinating scenario
for me
the scary night by mark h4 i don't like
the the same name as this as that as
thus
mandela elementary's cool grade 4k
4 000
daddy didn't check under my bed last
night oh no
well that's a shame
so i went to mommy's room
all right
i was scared there was scary knocking on
the door
uh-huh
i already know this story because
apparently i wrote it and the scariest
part is walking by the door
dark room by the stairs
[Applause]
scary yeah you right
yeah you right is that a door or is that
just the darkness of the basement almost
at mommy's room then i saw the man in
the corner
oh
well he doesn't look so bad
he didn't look bad at all
and then i fell asleep the end great
story me
thank you you're welcome
ah
good stuff
oh section two
ah
very little stress
but not no stress
ah
stress stress rising stress rising
quickly stress falling stress rising
stress surprising and then falling and
then rising and rising and then rising
non-stop until pumps
stress high stress extreme stress very
stress high strain extreme stress lots
of stress
stress
ah low stress
hi oh it's you
hey how you doing pal
intruder me you
me or you
module complete if anything unexpected
occurred during the test let your
advisor know immediately i mean all of
it was unexpected because i've never
seen it before so i didn't really know
what to expect
wow i didn't know that there was an
analog horror community but i love
analog horror
it's pretty fun
is that all
is anything at the end after credit
sequence no nothing that this is crazy
i've literally never heard of this stuff
i'm very impressed oh this came out
august so that's why you know anytime
something like this comes out i'm just
like ah good stuff very good stuff oh
it's a whole subreddit analog [ __ ] i
love that that's great anyway thank you
everybody so much for watching
foreign
you